This puffy stitch technique was shared
by Julie in our subscriber forum,
it produces a thick,
squishy fabric on the standard gauge
machine without any hand manipulation.
It's really best worked on an automatic
patterning machine,
although you could select needles
for every row. The stitch pattern
is simply a 1x1 pattern.
You could use this design or lock a
design with every other stitch being
selected. The object is to slip the same
needles throughout the pattern repeats.
The texture comes from slip stitch,
remember, with slip stitch,
the working yarn passes under the needles
being slipped. You'll slip every-
other-needle for 9 rows.
And then knit one row plain
across all of the needles.
Slip every other needle for 9rows and
then at one row over all of the needles.
Repeating this gives you raised puffy
ridges on the purl side
and creates a thick fabric.
Now you can play with the number of rows,
but be sure to be consistent and keep
the repeats to an even number.
Looking at the knit side, you can see
how every other stitch has been slipped.
This stitch pattern has a lot of stretch
width-wise,
but it's really quite stable lengthwise.
Julie used the stitch pattern
for a nice thick cover on a clothes hanger.
She also suggested using it for slippers.
Again, it's a great way to get a thick,
comfy fabric from a standard gauge machine.
For Brother knitters set up your stitch
pattern, either electronics or punch card.
Set the KC knob
so the machine reads the stitch pattern.
Push in both part buttons
and knit 9 rows.
The part buttons will be doing the slipping.
Disengage the part buttons
and knit one row plain.
Do it again, push in both part buttons,
knit 9 rows. Disengage the part
buttons again and knit one row.
And keep repeating for as long as you need
the piece. Because you're building up those
raised ridges, it's going to take
a lot of rows to create any length.
For Silver Singer, Studio knitters,
set-aside levers to knit in pattern.
Engage your electronics or lock your punch
card to select every other needle.
Set the cam lever to slip
and knit 9 rows.
Set the cam lever for plain
knitting, knit one row.
Cam lever to slip knit 9 rows.Cam lever
for plain knitting in one row.
Repeat for the desired length.
Have fun with this puffy stitch technique
and be sure to share how you've used it.